hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch screen junkies honest
trailers for Avengers headin game I'm
excited to check this out I'm supposed
to go on screen junkies news I think
twice this month go home they need me
didn't they name my call-out big man in
the screen journeys studio over here
it's red charting with Greg clear that
me being brain-dead is doing wonders
right he's skipping Jerry duty is more
hey yes what a victory this doing
wonders for my improv skills this
morning the relief is palpable enough
from here you got it by loopholes at 3
in the morning before he's supposed to
check in at 7:00 in the morning duty and
warrants how you can do it presented by
the boys taking the fight to superheroes
watch now only on Amazon Prime video
promoting the boys MCU movies prepare
for the final conclusion of the Infinity
Saga and also part two of Infinity
Ward's announcement film of phase three
into two things for it backdoor pilot
for about three Disney pleasures
exhausting adventures endgame the most
successful crowd-pleasing global film
franchise is back but since life on
Earth sucks now it's all about grief
grief driven movies killed major
depression are you crying
and despair down shoulda Kim Wallace
because today's escapist fantasy is in
becoming a superhero
it's going back to fix your mistakes
instead of scraping by in the winking
nightmare of your own failure that's
right based on my life five years have
passed since half the population
vanished or as introverts call it
winning the lottery after shortage has
forced directors to cast their sadness
my cry just reporting sir
now the Avengers must band together to
do it every big franchise does when they
write themselves into a corner time to
survive the heroes dissemble for right
now that's what I call Marvel - of your
fandom with several alternate camera
angles on the Avengers that drink now a
trip to the shield base where they store
all the movies closure dusty and a
daring raid to justify the existence of
Thor the dark world together by a whole
bunch of it is a joke you know many
times a paradox no matter how it is
justified and yeah unites with all your
favorite Marvel heroes who aren't
clogging over there or somewhere else
Captain America who after spending a
decade in the present day as learned
occurs look at guys butts is America's
Anna's store whoo it's okay to make bad
jokes about because he's also suffering
from a very realistic post-traumatic
stress disorder before the movie store I
know it's crazy
Paul guy who deals with the loss of his
family by having a very psychic midlife
crisis yeah who thinks to the Internet's
brain poisoning is a letdown every time
he's not inside Thanos is that yeah
Black Widow who finally gets a primary
storyline in one of these movies killing
herself to motivate the boys
makes it work as you can tell the
passage of time by her hair that's
something Rodie hoping and pray they
don't travel back before our men the
avengers play so many times the most
helpful thing she does is kill nebula
and Captain Marvel who's so powerful the
movie desperately buys excuses to leave
her out the things that are happening on
earth are happening everywhere so you
may not see me for a long time until he
comes up with an excuse to breather is
so marble can finally have her lead the
first all-female Avengers team-up shot
yeah we'll let them together the MCU is
most complex and motivated village yet
he did not taking his place his old dad
owes the new role Thanos younger old
Thanos you know the person who sits
unless anyone else do all the work on
this stone what will you do wait who's
single plants from space balls faceless
CGI army the likes of which we have
never seen before since his last two
faceless CGI armies but whatever
watching the fight Thunder camp was the
best moment of my life and I'm including
the birth of my children guys sorry kids
just not worthy so in a world where
everyone hates Game of Thrones now
everyone's worried about Star Wars and
Jacob Roley won't stop crapping on the
floor for legacy it's a minor miracle we
got a satisfying conclusion to a global
nerd franchise now you just do it again
forever for the entire story tired
deficient bad yeah punch woman captain
pledge
[Music]
Wow this house does clannish or in jail
acting by recruits Oh Jack Norseman tak
Jeremy Renner's one big line of acting
go downstairs go help they need you
right now
we need more Russo's give me more
Russo's I love you two point eight
billion oh my god active
turn on a pig man did this on this
trailer cast hideous laughter on you
that's a DND spell would you know by now
if you watched our new episode of fandom
uncovered Dungeons & Dragons episode was
brought to you by the clearly watched
the new series only on Amazon Prime
video
you thought it was epic voice guy but it
was me do medley of voices that was John
Bailey auditioning right five movie
right there
that was hilarious you did it again
perfect advertisement for this film what
else can we say about Avengers end game
that hasn't been said well they've
pretty much summed it up all here but
they did point out a few things that I
feel like a lot of people don't often
point out I love the whole resemblance
of grief that they showed here I think
every one of these characters is
specifically going through an obstacle
of grief and embodying it in their own
way which brings in line the whole thing
about Thor and him having you know the
weight gain and the PTSD and somehow
it's been okay to make fun of fat Thor
we can call him fat Thor or something
well people call them fat Thor John
messed up I know you want people to be
called little people
people still use the term midgets and
somehow that's what's going on would fat
Thor
should he be called overweigh Thor thick
Thor yes so for some reason we still
call them fat Thor and somehow it's not
offensive somehow people are writing
about it well I mean you know guy heard
that Chris Hemsworth basically opted to
stay fat the entire movie when the
original script had him shaping up
halfway through so he really wanted
people to be seen to feel you know like
their embrace the word fat that's the
point is that what do ya know is that is
that really what's going on yes
definitely so perfect
what's this all rain energy drink well
we think it's the Mansoor video I think
it's about time yeah rain in some focus
yeah
rain in some energy hmm maybe it'd take
full rains of your brainpower my snow
Joe is a collapsible coffee cup it's
made of silicone and plastic and it
comes with his own reusable strong weak
specifically we're told we can't
cross-promote that's right someone can
have competing where you could pour your
energy drink into how about you learn to
yes Sam what I've given you instead of
just changing the joke yes I'm glad
you've switched away from bang energy
drink to the far superior rain that's
done let's talk about Avengers and games
some more we haven't talked about it
enough I don't think people will ever
stop talking about it especially the
time travel elements well that's funny
about the time travel part I think it's
very clearly explained and I hate
somehow for a guy who's not that wise I
was able to pretty much latch on to the
way the time travel will work because I
thought they thoroughly explained it
Thor
I thought they clearly explained it in
the film yet when people saw the whole
Captain America thing was the resident
point that I hear you know I think that
was such a big upset but they really
surprised I didn't point that out
sometimes I noticed they dodged the
jokes that they expect them to make fun
of how did Captain America get all those
stones in there maybe because they know
their friends are but how should it
little bit dedicated to a whole separate
video I don't know the whole thing with
time travel especially with Captain
America just confused the [ __ ] out of
people but I'm like no guys it's it's a
different time I think the voice over it
is yeah it's one of those things where I
watched the movie and when I didn't
think about it very much it made sense
but I do think that this honest trailer
hits something on the nose which is like
maybe time travels a paradox no matter
how it gets justified after a certain
point is no matter which way you slice
it time travel is just gonna be a
paradox that is gonna find its own way
to not quite make airtight sense I feel
like this debate will never die no
matter how simply they explained it in
the film you know until we at least get
a bunch of video essays explaining you
know theoretical time-travel circa the
Avengers I really love that joke that
they've said about how they have to do
this over and over again forever yeah
well yeah they did nail this well they
did the impossible they pulled it off
and I think it's great that they at
least have this what do they call it the
Infinity Saga the fact that they have
this phase just completely done no
matter where they go from here they'll
always have this chapter of 21 films a
show but they have that you know they
can go debts like with Star Wars I kind
of feel like well they can do prequels
and they can do sequels but they'll
always have that original trilogy that
was amazing and then here it's the same
thing except instead of a trilogy it's
21 regardless of where they go from here
they'll always have this defining
chapter
I've actually this is gonna make me lose
so much street cred oh no the streets
man they're dangerous territory when you
say [ __ ] like this they're gonna be all
disrespectful they could be like
click-clack model I don't buy any of the
Marvel DVDs because I'm like there's
always gonna be another collector's
edition they got the Disney Plus service
coming out we live in us in a culture
where if you want to see any Marvel
movie chances are you can make that
happen within the next hour right I've
never bought any blu-rays but now that
the infinity saga is complete when
spider-man far from home comes
I'm sure there's gonna be some awesome
blu-ray collection that is released the
phases one through three box set yeah
and I'm gonna buy that and it's gonna
probably only cost like $1,000 then
whatever next platform above blu-ray
comes out I'll be getting that once the
Black Widow movie comes out yeah on top
of it you know when they have like an
Inc it's like when they did the rocky
franchise and then Creed at the end of
it yeah like why would I want to buy
that box yeah but I did this you know
the way I they have these Disney plush
shows you go to the theaters and you may
have people like do these marathons for
the Marvel films or even at home people
do these marathons are they gonna be
including the shows in theaters now well
are you it seems like it's just it's who
just to get the full package you could
have skipped the Netflix shows you could
have skipped agents of shield you could
not stay humans these new shows it seems
like you have to watch so for the
marathons are you gonna have to include
these what if you know it's like for
Thor the dark world you might not like
Thor the dark world but you could
squeeze in one movie you don't like but
if you like watch like you're like I
hate whan division what is the worst
title ever so I hate you know what it
just sounds like one division like this
sounds like what do we call it a look
through what a vision yeah it's like the
least inspired title I think we got
Falcon Wonder Soldier which you recall
it Sam Bucky Sam Bucky I think would be
great there with them you fit it right
in with like flea bag and Letterkenny
all those others my theory is they were
probably gonna call it vision and the
Scarlet Witch but they didn't want a
man's name first yeah that's right
that's the reason they went with one
division it sounds like a Wanda Sykes TV
network which I would actually I would I
would watch that I would watch one it
sounds like a fake last name one
division my name is Bert one division
it's good thing we're able to rein in
all these thoughts mmm totally honest
trailers great job to everyone who wrote
this John Bailey
great job on the voice-over I humbly and
privately and discreetly contributed to
that Facebook
charity donation thing for your personal
thing that you had going on because I'm
humble and I don't want attention for it
so for my twenty dollars I contributed
Bailey it's great I have no idea what
the because you don't care care about
him one you're so good at being humble
that I just have no idea what you're
talking about
hey guys did you like this honest
trailer I sure hope so you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell and say let's give a
patron in the day shout-out to someone
special today is dedicated to Josh
Walker
Josh beautiful man from the UK we
featured these last time but here's a
photo of him cosplaying as obese Thor
that's right then here's one of him as
Prince volton from Flash Gordon
[Music]
we did not recognize that before because
we dumb cuz sweet and Josh I sent you a
message a week ago and you haven't
gotten back to me in the past week if I
take a week to get back to you that's
one thing I'm a busy guy
you take a week to get back you have no
excuses you know you got nothing going
on get your [ __ ] together get back on
the keyboard and reply to me as soon as
you can quit being an a-hole that sounds
really nice so hurry on uh thanks for
being here buddy
thanks I'll show you out for your
cosplay photos which will get you
nowhere in your personal life or career
pursuits see ya